thank you
[Music]
all right y'all so asianization and only
white guys know of it Canadian rapper
Drake is certainly known these days for
putting the odd bet on UFC fights oh
dude yo he's like a hell of a big
Gambler usually for a lot a lot of money
he's been losing a lot and luck is not
on his side all the time this weekend he
lost a staggering 430 thousand dollars I
would get like the occasional reels that
pop up where Drake is like playing
Blackjack for like a million dollars
like oh yeah whatever somebody 60 Grand
to play but he's like promoting like a
gambling fan that's what I heard too
it's the online thing that they pay you
to like promote it no but this one is
like a regular bet he bet 200 000 on
Kumar uh Camaro Usman to defeat the
British fighter Leon Edwards any lazy
the British person one this also comes
after earlier in that same night he had
bet on Jose Aldo to beat marab however
did you say that fine
double loss yeah that stake was worth
more than the Camaro fight that was 230
000 for him do you know if he's betting
with the odds are against him
those are big favorites damn that's too
bad that Drake curse yeah right anytime
he's in somebody's Corner walking with
him they lose oh she's the only one that
broke it he's the only one that broke
the curve Jim Kramer of fight betting
I see really is though he like for
example
um and even on this past fight he had
originally only bet 149 000 on Camaro uh
but then he spent another 49 000 to win
in the fourth round so you just added on
to it oh man because a lot of people
think Kamara Usman is like the lock
right he's the safest pick and then he
lost this past weekend in a devastating
fashion and it was like a very big upset
what's devastating fashion he was up he
was gonna win the fight he was whooping
the other guy's ass it was the
equivalent of being up by 20 points in
the fourth quarter with a minute to go
and he got ko'd in the last minute
and it was like hectic it was crazy
upset of the Year oh dude it's it might
be the up one of the upsets of like the
decade that must have made some people a
lot of money then that's Sarah and GSP
was probably the biggest one ever but as
far as like that was the big one because
Matt Sarah was supposed to get destroyed
by GSP but he Leon Edwards was losing by
a staggering margin yeah he looked like
he was there was no way the commentators
were like he needs to do something like
he it's over the fight's over he's never
gonna get a shot again yeah like this is
it for him you know this can't happen
and it was out of a movie he knocked him
out and the guy that won his nickname is
Rocky you know like he's [ __ ] crazy
dude like it doesn't make sense and the
fight that he had before this Leon
Edwards the guy who won he was fighting
Nate Diaz and the he was beating Nate
Diaz up for five rounds the last minute
he almost got ko'd with a slap with yeah
yeah and then eventually the same thing
happens but the reverse for him in this
fight and the only reason why Leon
didn't lose in the last fight is because
Nate Diaz after he like wobbles them
instead of pouncing on his ass he was
like flipping him off and like pointed
out so he let him like he let him
recover
y yeah so it was pretty [ __ ] crazy
it's like a strategy day but Drake is
cursed it seems like anybody he bets on
it seems like they win those would be
the fights for you to bet on since
you're always going Underdog yeah
whatever bet the opposite of Drake if
he's doing the favorite Underdog Joe
let's go yeah Drake's uh first public
bet came back in March where he staked
an incredible two uh 275 000 on Jorge as
well to beat Colby Covington that was a
bad bad and Covington resembly be his
competitor two months later their rapper
elected to bet on an outsider putting
down four hundred thousand dollars on
Justin gay
beating uh Charles oliviera yeah but I
wonder how much that is relatively he
makes for like 50 bucks yeah I said
staggering was like is it staggering for
him though yeah yeah he's hotline bling
I mean either way though it's still like
taking 400 000 and then just like losing
that and like a short amount of time on
a favorite person that must still be
like but what percentage of that is your
your worth you know because like if I
only have 100 bucks to my name 25 is a
quarter Network yeah you know but it's
400 Grand even a percent of his work
tiny decimal yeah and we don't know how
he stopped that out of my wallet he
dropped it out of his wallet I mean his
his match is 100 million dollars right
you know he could like just take like a
chisel like take 100 grand out of his
wall yeah
this will come for the best horrible
tile yeah this is this million dollar
stucco Justice battle with the other
sports events on
like all like basketball football
baseball he always always loses
stay away from this guy on me please
please stop exactly though when he did
win with the Israel out of Sonya he
ended up taking home around a million
dollars so that's that big there it kind
of covers three of his last fight he
also bet on these two British fighters
who fought in the UK patty pimblet patty
the Maddie and the Molly McCann right
and he won a good amount of money and he
called him up I was like honestly send
you guys a Rolex I said both you guys
which is pretty fun that's pretty cool
but like that was the other time he won
but who knows that is like the universal
like I'm ballin here's a great gift that
you won't turn down here's a Rollie yeah
yeah yeah yeah everybody's like a Rollie
man and it holds value too so he could
reset oh yeah dude it's freaking crazy
appreciates he made a 220 000 bet
outside of USC on a guy named Charles
Leclerc to win the Spanish Grand Prix in
Formula One only for the driver to
retire from the race due to an engine
failure after starting
bad luck dude
that's kind of funny the horse runs on
the track yeah it just runs the opposite
way it looks like Mouse to the Palace
the Hoops follow up it says uh it never
happens
prior to this just spending time with
Drake appeared to be enough to lead to a
catastrophic sporting loss oh [ __ ]
footballers such as Sergio Aguero
pierre-emerick aubameyang and Jaden's
sister too busy party yeah that's a real
car so lose matches shortly after being
photographed with the musician oh my God
just for the pictures other sports stars
like Serena Williams and Anthony Joshua
have also been hit by the Drake curse
dude it's a curse real thing man it's
getting everybody now no one's like hey
don't meet a grease don't meet a grease
don't even say hi we can't hang out with
you Drake make sure shark don't come
he's like he's gonna make a song about
how he doesn't get invited to parties
dude I bet if you were an athlete like
on the week of your fight or whatever
competition and you hang out with Drake
that's a huge distraction
mess with your head yeah because your
head you're like oh I made it I'm
chilling with Drake you know I won't
even let him into my locker room yeah
you better stay your ass up so acting
curses man I'm like you just don't you
just don't go around it yeah
explanation I just need to know no yeah
so on your next fight [ __ ] Drake hits
you up and he goes hang out after my
fight he's like you win I'll give you a
Rollie so you got to see me now and I
was like is it over 20 grand because we
had that wager right anything over 20
grand this will be on the list okay you
could come Jake those datejust the gold
ones those are over 20. say hey how come
this one's clicks one at a time
you know [ __ ] like you're on top of
the world you're like it's my biggest
fight ever Drake hits you trying to hang
out and that's all you can think about
you're like [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] please don't
hang out with me Drake honestly if you
can hang out with my opponent that'll
make me really happy
that's great send him over you just
better wish that he's on someone else's
corner do you guys ever see because he's
from Toronto right is that right yeah
you guys ever see the clip of when the
Toronto Raptors NBA team they won the
championship and they started
interviewing Drake because he was there
he's a huge Toronto Raptors fan they
were interviewing him like he was on the
[ __ ] team dude and they're like what
do you think about the championship why
they won in that Viral clip where he's
like talking about like yo man I'm just
like happy for my city and he's like I
want my chip with the dip he kept saying
that stupid ass phrase and he went viral
because he was like being interviewed by
these NBA reporters asking about like
what do you think the team attributes
their success to and he's like taking
like not taking credit but he's in a way
like he's talking like he's a player
he's like yeah it's like shut up Drake
we worked hard all year for this and we
made it happen we pulled it off Raptors
yeah dude and it's just like oh man
there's a lot of memes of him like
hanging out with players like looking
like he's part of the bench right yeah
yes I always see those yeah and he but
he's always like he always looks like
he's bugging them kind of they're all
like huddled and he's just like
what's going on guys what's the next
play What's the next play
did you guys ever get into sports
betting in a in a in a major way because
I've never done it but I really want to
after we bet together what's what's
major to you like the way we did crypto
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] no dude
that's too heartbreaking at least it'll
be quick because I'm playing with Drake
numbers and I don't got Drake Money
curse so far
yeah man no like
Drake hung out with [ __ ] Dole Quan
the day before the [ __ ] dropped oh my
God
photo surfaces I actually do Luna that
day more money table games than I did
sports betting because of sports betting
we did it together that was my first
time but after that I was like oh [ __ ] I
can see how this gets so addicting
because now you can study the fighters
and the game and you can be like all
right I think I know which ones are
gonna have better odds you know and when
you watch the game it's that much more
exciting too we'd have money we didn't
even watch the game yeah not together at
least we should do it next time together
start Banning some fights and then let's
go Drake mode on the on the BET yeah
well whatever Drake bets on WE bet the
odd obviously yeah yeah I think that'd
be interesting like experiment to see
like what happens
if we do end up being profitable we
break we break the curse we break the
curse yeah we broke the trade curse we
all lost our money yeah
Drake's been winning
we're the reason why he gets more money
then he sends us Rollies
foreign
[Music]